je retiens de lui son extrême courtoisie
sa très grande capacité d'écouté et sa
volonté de toujours s'intéresser de très
près à ce que ses interlocuteurs
ça faisait ce qu'il avait en face de lui
avec un milieu je retienne tout d'abord
que c'était un grand européen européen
commun que la même vue lors du
référendum aux autres ou en effet il a
pu à nouveau défendre ses positions
européennes et je crois que c'est un
novateur la de là dessus il ya les
relations avec avec l'allemagne très
importante et je crois que l'amitié
franco allemande
c'est vraiment nourrit aussi avec ce
président valéry giscard d'estaing
on a effectivement de très grandes
avancées durant son septennat je pense
pas mal abaissement
la bri à 18 ans je pense notamment à son
combat qu'il a mené
simone veil pour le droit à l'avortement
dans d'autres combats qu'il a rarement
aussi je pense notamment au divorce par
consentement mutuel non
tout ceci ce sont aussi les faits
marquants du septennat de valéry giscard
d'estaing